Moin. Oh.
Sech. Wartet mal. Irgendwas stimmt hier nicht.
Irgendwas ist hier nicht richtig drin.
So. Nö.
Was ist denn das schon wieder?
Windows, Alter.
So, ich glaube jetzt funzt es halbwegs.
Ja, man weiß ja nicht.
Wobei. Richtig?
Sekunde.
Test, Test. Blub, blub, blub.
Ja, okay.
Scheint doch zu funzen.
Ich weiß nicht. Ein paar Tage nicht on gewesen.
Schon hat Windows gleich wieder alles umgestellt.
Warum auch immer, gell?
Da kann man mal einen Trost proben.
Leute, ich habe richtig scheiße gepennt heute Nacht.
Ich gehe. Ups.
Aus. Das war.
Das war kühl.
Dann kühl.
Dann wieder super warm.
Und heute ist es wieder kühl.
Oh, was wollen sie haben?
Introducing Workstation Pro.
17.6.
Aha.
Okay, was gibt's denn?
Windows 2025 Support.
Okay, ganz ehrlich.
Da kann ich drauf verzichten.
Ich bin mir sogar ziemlich sicher, dass das auch jetzt schon auf wird.
In der, in der alten Version.
Windows 11 letzte.
Es gibt eine neue VMware CLI.
Das ist cool, aber bei Desktop Virtualisierung ist das jetzt nicht so relevant.
Hätten die PCI Pass Through für Windows, wäre ich natürlich sofort am Start.
Aber sowas gibt's natürlich nicht.
Und wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht geben.
Legacy VM Tools no longer shipped.
Ja, das juckt mich jetzt auch nicht, ob da Windows 95 Tools dabei sind oder nicht.
Man kann die sich ja immer noch runterladen.
Keine. Man kann keine alten Drucker Anschlüsse, Parallel Ports mehr benutzen.
Aber es ist duplicate.
Das heißt, es geht immer noch.
Es wird aber nicht mehr Support.
Ja, okay. Juckt mich jetzt mal gar nicht.
Moin. Jemand von euch gestern?
Ich frage jetzt schon mal, sind noch nicht viele Leute da, aber vielleicht.
Äh, NoLimitX. Oh, danke schön für den Sub.
By the way.
Okay.
Ähm, jemand gestern von der Bahngeschichte in Frankfurt betroffen gewesen?
Gibt's jetzt, hab ich mich sogar bei 123456 ver...
Oh nein, Passwort liegt, Leute.
Shit.
Seid ihr schon drin?
Wer ist schon am Start?
Nein, Frankfurt war ja gestern...
Ziemlich...
Ziemlich Bahnchaos.
Also ich, ich hab's nicht mitgekriegt.
Aber es muss wohl deutschlandweit Auswirkungen gehabt haben.
Sollen wir mal Package Updates...
Package Updates.
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange der Stream heute geht.
Ich hab echt nicht gut gepennt.
Ich hab sogar echt mal meinen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch wieder hochgefahren.
Nachdem ich jetzt irgendwie den, keine Ahnung, 10 Jahre gar nicht benutzt hab.
Dass ich nicht einpenn.
Updates, ja.
Arch, by the way.
Wobei ich habe den Eindruck, Arch, by the way, hat etwas seine Coolness verloren.
Seitdem die richtig coolen Leute nix, by the way, usen.
Natürlich ist das auch blöde.
Weil die richtig krassen Hackermen-Leute, die verwenden Arch, by the way, mit nix.
Zusammen.
Deshalb überlegen die einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch.
Ja, gute Sache.
Gute Sache.
Kann man nur recommenden.
Um auf möglichst viel Denglisch zu sagen.
Also ich kann das nur empfehlen.
Einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch.
Auch wenn ich den selten verwende.
Der Arbeit hab ich auch einen.
Da verwende ich ihn auch selten.
Ab und zu mal.
Ich hab übrigens wieder demnächst...
Demnächst.
Auf der Arbeit.
Das jährliche Team-Building-Event.
Das ist kein Event, wie man sich das vorstellt.
Sodass da irgendwie hingefahren wird.
Und Action gemacht wird.
Sondern es ist so ein...
Workshop mit irgend so einem...
Ich bin nicht Psychologen, Trainer und Wut dabei.
Das war das letzte Mal.
Ey, ihr wisst ja, ich hab überhaupt keinen Bock auf solche Sachen.
Ich hatte das letzte Mal auch keinen Bock.
Ich hab jetzt auch keinen Bock.
Aber das ging halbwegs klar.
Naja.
Ähm.
Ich würde sagen...
Es ist nichts, wo man sich dazwischen entscheiden müsste.
Ist beides praktisch.
Regelmäßig bewegen und einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch.
Wenn man sich jetzt natürlich entscheiden muss,
auch für einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch
oder ein paar ordentliche Laufschuhe,
würde ich sagen, vielleicht lieber ein paar ordentliche Laufschuhe mehr bewegen.
Ein höhenverstellbarer Schreibtisch macht am ehesten Sinn mit einem G-Laufband.
Naja.
Also ich finde, man kann ja auch...
Also auch ohne ein Laufband kann man...
Mache ich jetzt übrigens auch gerade.
Sich so ein bisschen auf- und abbewegen vorm Schreibtisch.
Ja, also...
Ja, natürlich mit einem Laufband ist es nochmal...
Nochmal besser.
Da kannst du nämlich quasi geradeaus weitergucken und vorwärts laufen.
Aber so geht das auch schon.
Am Ende ist das ja recht individuell, was den Leuten da am besten bekommt.
Die ganzen Rust-Hackermans, MoneyRust.de.
Updaten.
Wieso? Ich glaube, jetzt haben wir alles...
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ganz ehrlich, die gehen mir so unglaublich...
Geht es da nur um Windows auf Arm oder...
Das ist halt so die typische Microsoft-Taktik, ne?
Das war so klar.
Ich bilde mir sogar ein, ich habe das gesagt,
dass ich sowas vermute, als wir das erste Mal drüber geredet haben.
Das ist so die übliche Microsoft-Taktik.
Es wird irgendwas angekündigt, die Leute finden es scheiße.
Microsoft rudert zurück, weil das halt schlechte Publicity ist.
Und dann denken sie sich, oh, mir doch egal.
Habe ich das jetzt schon drauf oder mit was kommt das jetzt?
Ich will das nämlich nicht.
Ich habe keinen Bock, dass Microsoft alles aufzeichnet, was ich auf meinem Desktop mache.
Gutes Bild.
Ja, Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof gestern, so wie es aussieht, hä?
Alter, ist das voll.
Ich meine, das ist von Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof eh schon voll.
Aber hier ist es unnormal.
Wisst ihr, was ich gemacht hätte?
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass Straßenbahn und U-Bahn,
und sowas, weitergefahren sind.
Weiß das jemand?
Weiß jemand, ob Straßenbahn und U-Bahn weitergefahren sind?
Vermutlich.
Weil die haben ja mit der Bahn an sich nichts zu tun.
Ich weiß jetzt halt nicht, was genau betroffen war,
und ob das vielleicht auch Straßenbahn und U-Bahn betrifft.
Also ich denke mal, die sind weitergefahren.
Also was ich, S-Bahn wahrscheinlich nicht,
weil die auf den Schienen von der Bahn fahren.
Also was ich gestern gemacht hätte, wenn ich da gewesen wäre,
wäre übrigens Samstag auch noch ein Scheiß-Tag, ne, dafür.
Gerade weil auch Leute zum Flughafen müssen.
Naja.
U-Bahnen sind zum Teil auch rausgefallen, wenn sie ge- okay.
Naja, gehen wir mal davon aus, dass Straßenbahn und U-Bahn noch funktioniert hätten.
Also was ich gemacht hätte, wäre folgendes.
Als erstes hätte ich probiert, ein Taxi zu kriegen,
was wahrscheinlich nicht möglich gewesen wäre.
Gehe ich mal davon aus, weil es einfach zu voll ist, zu viel.
Was ich gemacht hätte, ist,
ich wäre wahrscheinlich mit der Straßenbahn nach Main-Tal gefahren.
Äh, nicht nach Main-Tal.
Nach Main-Kur.
Frankfurt-Main-Kur, das ist der letzte,
quasi der letzte Bahnhof,
wo man, äh, hinkommt, mit so einer Frankfurter Straßenbahn in Richtung Hanau.
So.
Und wenn's hart auf- wenn's super hart auf hart gekommen wäre,
hätte ich von da laufen müssen.
Das hätte eine Weile gedauert.
Aber wäre,
das hat man mal im Bereich des Möglichen gewesen.
Ich hätte mich abholen lassen können,
weil's jemand gerade am Start ist.
Oder,
vielleicht hätte ich Glück gehabt und, äh, hätte mit dem Bus weiterfahren können.
Weil ich glaube, die wenigsten,
sind in Main-Kur am Start.
Es ballt sich in Frankfurt vermutlich,
hauptsächlich am Hauptbahnhof
und am Südbahnhof.
Ist jetzt meine Vermutung mal, ja.
Hauptbahnhof und Südbahnhof.
Von Main-Kur nach Hanau laufen wir, klar, warum nicht?
Das ist ein Stück.
Aber das geht.
Maps.
Frankfurt.
Ah, heute wohne ich mal wieder in Main-Kur.
Hier.
Gehe ich richtig?
Also das müssten, das müssten von mir-
das müsste von hier
zu mir heim, so ungefähr
18 Kilometer oder so sein, würde ich mal vermuten,
auf der Main-Seite.
Äh, Route.
Von hier?
Machen wir mal irgendwie Hanau.
Machen wir mal irgendwie.
Ich will mich jetzt nicht zu sehr leaken.
Machen wir mal, ähm,
was ist denn so
halbwegs in der Nähe?
Äh,
Gartencenter Wolfgang.
Achso, hier.
Nee, nicht Gärtnerei, da will ich nicht hin, aber
mal hier so in der Ecke.
Ja, irgendwie.
Ja, also das würde,
das sind, okay, das ist, Google sagt,
direkter Weg sind
15, 15 Kilometer,
15 Kilometer, wobei
ganz ehrlich,
das ist wahrscheinlich nicht den
Weg, den ich laufen würde.
Weil das gut geht, das ist eigentlich immer am
Main lang. Doch, den würde ich laufen,
den kenne ich nicht, den Weg, den bin ich noch nie gelaufen.
Ich kenne
den Weg hier auf der Seite, aber
dann müsste man ja, dann müsste man ja immer noch hier über den
Main, ja. Also eigentlich
blödsinnig.
Ja, doch.
Ich glaube, das geht klar.
Da bräuchte ich ungefähr 3 Stunden.
Ich bräuchte keine, ich bräuchte keine
dreieinhalb, ich bräuchte ungefähr 3 Stunden,
wenn ich da halbwegs zügig laufe.
Ja, also das wäre wahrscheinlich
mein Plan gewesen, hätte ich
gestern hier gestanden.
Irgendwie mit der Straßenbahn nach
Mainkur fahren, weil das irgendwie das äußerste ist,
was es hier gibt. Hauptbahnhof ist hier unten,
irgendwo da.
Hauptbahnhof, das ist ein Stück,
was man spart, so.
Ne, ne, ne.
Nach Hanau selbst,
je nachdem, wo du, das gehört ja hier
quasi auch schon irgendwie dazu, ja.
Wenn du hier, wenn du hier jetzt wohnen würdest,
ist es sogar noch viel näher.
Aber ich habe jetzt halt mal hier eingegeben, weil ich nicht,
ich will jetzt nicht exakt liegen, wo ich wohne, ne.
Ne, aber
es passt.
Das geht klar, also ungefähr 15 Kilometer.
15 Kilometer, ich meine,
ich hätte jetzt da keinen großen Bock drauf
gehabt, 15 Kilometer zu laufen, ja.
Aber
15 Kilometer, wenn's
denn sein muss, weil man halt sonst aus Frankfurt nicht
wegkommt und man davon ausgehen kann,
dass sich dieses Chaos
wahrscheinlich nicht in drei Stunden
von selber erledigt.
Und selbst wenn, musst du ja erstmal wegkommen.
Selbst wenn sich das erledigt, dass es wieder geht,
heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass du innerhalb
der nächsten drei Stunden daheim irgendwie bist.
Also,
na, so hätte ich das wahrscheinlich
nicht gemacht.
Wäre dann heimgelaufen.
Oder, was natürlich auch funktioniert hätte, ist,
vielleicht hätte ich mich abholen lassen können,
dann wäre ich vielleicht ein Stück hier runtergelaufen.
Wo dann nichts mehr los ist.
Ja, vielleicht hätte man, vielleicht hätte man
hier dann auch irgendwie noch wieder ein Taxi gekriegt.
Mal gucken. Ja, also das würde ich, das, hätte ich gesagt,
okay, das, aber das, das hätte ich
das hätte ich ausprobiert.
50 Kilometer, das passt.
Gestern bin ich 10 Kilometer,
genau, also nicht gerannt,
natürlich normal spazieren gegangen.
10 Kilometer, das hat ungefähr 2 Stunden gedauert,
so 1,49, äh, 1,59,
knapp 2 Stunden.
Das war jetzt nicht geschlendert,
aber auch nicht mega schnell gelaufen.
Oder, naja, ich habe,
ich habe ehrlich gesagt Uber noch nie verwendet.
Wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Seid ihr schon mal Uber gefahren?
Ich habe halt so den,
die Vermutung, dass gestern weder Taxis
noch Uber irgendwie hier
bei dem Chaos viel verfügbar waren.
Ja, Roller ausleihen,
wäre auch sehr schlau gewesen,
aber ich gehe auch davon aus, dass es
zu dem Zeitpunkt wahrscheinlich keinen Roller mehr gab.
Was auch, was auch möglich gewesen wäre,
so ein Bahnfahrrad oder sowas,
aber wie gesagt, ich vermute, dass
am Hauptbahnhof
alles, alles schon weg gewesen wäre.
Also irgendwie nach Mainkur hätte ich auf jeden Fall fahren müssen.
Vielleicht hätte ich da noch einen Roller
oder ein Fahrrad oder irgendwas gefunden.
Ja, aber ich bin froh,
Leute, dass ich gestern nicht in Frankfurt war
und mich mit diesem Shit
nicht auseinandersetzen muss. Guckt euch das mal an, ey.
Das ist wahrscheinlich, sieht man hier irgendwas?
Wahrscheinlich auch wieder null Infos
gewesen, was Sache ist.
Die sieht auch nicht sonderlich happy aus hier.
Microsoft will die Systemsteuerung
immer noch entfernen.
Ja, das ist doch, das habe ich letztens auch schon gelesen.
Ich habe bis jetzt
nichts gefunden, also das letzte,
was ich vermutet habe, war ja hier diese
die Netzwerksettings waren das, glaube ich,
die ich das letzte Mal nicht über die normale Systemsteuerung
gefunden habe.
Aber sogar diese nicht.
Die sind ja mittlerweile da.
Registry Editor, ja.
Na komm, Windows ohne Regedit
werden wir nicht sehen.
Ah doch, das ist schon eine Nummer härter
als sonst am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Auch Samstagsmittags.
Ohne Regedit kannst du vergessen,
äh, wenn es kein Regedit
mehr gibt, dann gibt es innerhalb
von, wahrscheinlich gibt es das schon,
auf GitHub, dann gibt es innerhalb
von drei Sekunden,
nachdem diese Meldung rauskommt,
ein Open Source Regedit.
Weil, ganz ehrlich, ohne Regedit,
wie sollen denn diese ganzen Newsseiten
15, 15 krasse
Windows-Tipps, die nicht mal Microsoft kennt,
in ihre Sachen reinschreiben,
so wie früher?
Da muss es Regedit geben, Alter.
Ohne Regedit kann ich mir das
nicht vorstellen. Und es gibt ja,
und wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich kann man diesen Shit hier dann auch
nur abschalten, gescheit über
Registry. Was ist das? Wollte ich eh mal lesen.
Hab ich Recall?
Wo kommt, wo bekommt man denn Recall überhaupt
her? Okay, Insider
Testers bekommen das im Oktober.
Also, das könnte tatsächlich zum
Jahr des Linux-Desktops werden.
Guck mal,
jetzt, jetzt, jetzt mal ernsthaft, ja.
Glaubt das
jemand, Microsoft,
dass das, ähm,
für immer Opt-In bleiben wird
und Disabled by Default? Ich glaub
das denen nicht. Also, ich glaube denen,
dass die das nach diesem
großen
Stress, den es da
jetzt gab und nach diesem
Public, äh, so, so Outcry
und Geflame,
glaub ich denen, dass das erstmal
Disabled sein wird. Jaja, das glaub ich denen
schon. Aber
was ich denen nicht glaube ist,
dass das nicht dann irgendwie im
übernächsten Update, äh,
zufälligerweise Enabled ist
und wenn es dann wieder zu groß, zu
zu, zu großem Aufschrei
kommt, sagt Microsoft,
ups,
das war ja gar keine Absicht, dass das
standardmäßig Enabled war, aber
das ist ein Bug, aber
jetzt ist es passiert,
ihr könnt's ja selbst wieder ausschalten.
Ja, und irgendwann in
drei Jahren oder so, gibt's dann
dann nicht mal mehr den Ausschaltknopf.
Aber wisst ihr, das ist das erste Windows-Feature,
was mich ernsthaft
dazu bringen könnte,
Windows runterzuschmeißen.
Brauchst, ja, gut,
also solange du noch nen Co-Pilot
Plus-PC brauchst und da sind
diese armen Dinger und mit extra,
dann, ne, wenn, wenn, wenn das nicht geht,
aber das ist wirklich das erste Windows-Feature,
ich mein, es ist viel, es ist viel Shit
bei Windows dabei, da sind wir uns einig, aber
das ist das erste Windows-Feature, was
ich so wenig haben
will, dass ich vielleicht
sogar die
Gaming-Probleme
und, und, ja, Software, die da
nicht geht und sowas
mit Linux in Kauf nehmen würde, weil,
bei mir ist es halt so, ich bin sehr glücklich
so mit meinem Setup, wie das aktuell ist,
dass ich Linux hab für alles
andere, hier
auf dem zweiten Desktop, Fullscreen
und Windows, wenn's um
Video-Gaming und, und
bisschen Thumbnail erstellen
und so Gedulds geht. Ja, ich find, das
ist ne gute,
gute Kombination, die auch
ganz gut funzt.
War noch ganz schön warm, oder?
Vielleicht wird's denn zu kälter, ey.
Guck mal, wie viel ist es denn draußen?
26 Grad ist es draußen, immer noch relativ
warm, ja. Was hier drinnen ist,
mal kurz auf meinen Thermometer
gucken. Ja, hier drinnen ist 26,3,
aber ich will jetzt auch nicht die, die
Klimaanlage anschmeißen.
Kann man Gaming betreiben auf Linux?
Ja.
Kannst du? Mittlerweile sogar besser,
als es je vorher funktioniert hat.
Du hast aber, je nachdem,
also je nachdem, was du,
was du spielen willst,
hast du immer noch Probleme.
Das betrifft hauptsächlich Anti-
Cheat, also Spiele mit
ziemlich tief integriertem
Anti-Cheat.
Wenn du sowas wie Rainbow Six
spielen willst, oder Fortnite, oder
was weiß ich, PUBG, weiß ich
gar nicht. Modern Warfare,
Warzone, wahrscheinlich auch nicht
richtig. Halt so,
Dinger. Spiele mit Anti-
Cheat gehen nicht.
Und
die werden wahrscheinlich auch in Zukunft
nicht gehen. Mario, danke schön für den Sub.
Die werden wahrscheinlich in Zukunft auch nicht richtig funktionieren.
Das ist halt das Problem.
Der Rest funktioniert
ganz brauchbar.
Was Videoschnitt angeht,
kann man sich sicherlich, da gibt es wenigstens
Alternativen, kann man sich vielleicht dran gewöhnen.
Was ich ein bisschen blöd finde, ist,
dass es keinen
Affinity Designer gibt.
Das bin ich zum Thumbnails erstellen
ganz gut, da habe ich mich jetzt dran gewöhnt.
Ich werde bestimmt nicht mit Gimp anfangen. Ich finde,
das ist so eines der, weiß nicht,
grausamsten Programme,
wenn man sie sich anguckt,
ever.
Mag sein, dass man damit einiges
machen kann, aber
allein schon, wenn ich die Oberfläche sehe
und Gimp öffne, da
habe ich schon keinen
Bock mehr, das zu verwenden.
Weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
Paint.net, wird das noch entwickelt?
Also, wenn du mit nur Singleplayer Games
klar kommst, ich meine,
was natürlich auch noch ein Problem sein kann,
ist Singleplayer Games,
mit
sehr tiefgreifendem
Kopierschutz. Da bin ich mir
allerdings nicht sicher, aber ich glaube,
ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass das
auch Probleme machen kann.
Ich weiß es nicht,
ich weiß es nicht genau, aber ich bin mir da relativ sicher,
dass es da sicherlich die ein oder anderen Games gibt, die
wie hieß denn
dieser Kram, dieser Kopierschutz, der quasi
so eine halbe
VM startet erstmal
und
Kernel-Mode-Zeugs braucht und so, dass es
funktioniert, was ja glücklicherweise
immer weniger Games verwenden.
Wobei, das ist mein Gefühl, ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt.
Ja, ja, genau, das meine ich.
Es gibt da bestimmt noch mehr in diese Richtung
und da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es dort
Probleme mit Linux gibt, das weiß ich
aber nicht, aber ich bin mir da relativ sicher,
weil ich wüsste nicht,
ja, da ist ja nicht so viel Unterschied zwischen
Anti-Cheat und sowas, warum es nicht
geht.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das auch problematisch
ist unter Linux.
Zum großen Teil,
also zum großen und ganzen
würde ich sagen,
kommst du eigentlich mit
Gaming unter Linux mittlerweile ganz
gut klar.
Du hast natürlich so die grundsätzliche
Problematik, dass wenn irgendwas neu rauskommt
und du das startest, also du
kaufst dir das und du startest das, du weißt halt
davor erstmal nicht, geht das denn
ab dem ersten Tag. Da kannst du dir
unter Windows ja relativ sicher sein. Natürlich sind die
Spiele teilweise unfertig und
bugged und sowas, ja, das ist ja was anderes.
Aber zumindest, dass sie halt
mal starten und laufen,
so wie es der Hersteller so im ersten Blick sich gedacht hat.
Da kannst du dir halt
unter Windows sicher sein,
weil das die einzige Plattform ist, außer
die Konsolen, wo das die Hersteller ausprobieren
und dafür vertreiben. Die Chancen
sind mittlerweile relativ gut, dass es unter Linux
funktioniert, aber du hast halt keine
so wirklich Sicherheit da. Also kann
auch sein, dass du dir mal was kaufst
zum Releasetag und es dann funktioniert.
Ja, es gibt jetzt ja beispielsweise diesen neuen
Warhammer Third Person Shooter,
der auf den ersten Blick ein bisschen aussieht
wie Gears of War.
Und
wenn man sich vorstellt, man kauft das, ja,
keiner hat es bisher ausprobiert unter Linux
und ich weiß das übrigens gar nicht. Wir können
mal kurz gucken, ob das funktioniert, ja.
Das würde mich mal interessieren, das ist so ein gutes
Beispiel jetzt.
Läuft Concord auf Linux?
Ist das nicht mittlerweile sogar schon eingestellt?
Ja, ProtonDB wollte
ich jetzt auch gucken. Gut, dass du es sagst.
Gucken wir doch mal.
Gears Marine 2.
Hm, wisst ihr, man weiß es noch nicht.
Also, ach so,
ja gut.
Das Game kommt, glaube ich, morgen auch erst raus.
Also, man weiß es noch nicht,
ja. Das ist halt so ein Ding,
es kann sein, dass du dir das kaufst,
installierst, startest
und es geht nicht. Was so bei ganz
neuen Games bestimmt ab und zu mal der Fall
ist. Wie gesagt, ich weiß es nicht
genau, weil ich betreibe das ja selbst
nicht unter Linux, so wenn es ums Thema
Gaming geht. Eines der Gründe, warum
ich hier noch meine Windows-Kiste am Start habe.
Kann man modden unter Linux?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht so
genau, was du meinst. Du meinst, wenn du
Skyrim zum Beispiel hast, willst du Mod installieren?
Klar, wenn das Spiel Mod-Support hat, ist
kein Problem. Das ist, glaube ich,
unter Linux und Windows erst einmal relativ wurscht.
Wobei,
ne, stimmt nicht. Je nachdem, was du brauchst,
ob das, wie gut das unter
Linux läuft, ist natürlich auch noch eine Frage.
Ich weiß nicht, wie gut der Unity-Mod-Manager
beispielsweise, Out of the
Sky, das ist Unity, da würde ich mal vermuten,
dass das ganz brauchbar funktioniert.
Hängt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen
vom Spiel ab und wie offiziell
der Mod-Support ist. Also, wenn das
Spiel offiziell einen Mod-Support hat, so nach dem
Motto, ja,
lege die Mods in diesem
Verzeichnis ab und das Spiel lädt die bei Start und so,
dann wird das wahrscheinlich auch unter Linux funktionieren.
Aber wenn das so ein
Hacky Mod-Support
ist, wo du irgendwie einen Third-Party
Mod-Manager brauchst,
der das dann, ist die Frage,
wie gut das funktioniert. Nachdem das Game einmal
gepatcht ist mit den Mods, dann wird es wahrscheinlich
auch unter Linux funktionieren, wenn das Game an sich
unter Linux läuft. Das sind halt so ein bisschen
die kleinen Unsicherheiten, die du hast,
wenn du hauptsächlich unter
Linux für Gaming unterwegs bist. Im Großen
und Ganzen würde ich sagen, ist das mittlerweile
echt ganz gut.
Und wem haben wir es zu verdanken, Leute?
Wem haben wir es zu verdanken?
Ich bin jetzt nicht sicher, wo habe ich denn...
Ja.
Wem haben wir es zu verdanken?
Zumindest zu einem großen Teil.
Haben wir es zu verdanken,
die
das nicht erst
seit dem Steam Deck machen.
Man darf ja nicht vergessen, dass
die Entwicklung,
was Proton und
die ganzen Wine Extensions
und dieses komische
wie heißt das,
dieses DirectX auf
Balken und
Kram, was es da alles gibt,
das hat ja schon vor dem Steam Deck
angefangen. Das ist im Endeffekt
ja auch,
dass das Steam Deck
mit der Versuch von Valve ist,
mal aus dieser ganzen
Kohle, die sie da reingesteckt haben, auch mal
ein bisschen Kapital zu schlagen.
Ist auch gut so.
Ist übrigens auch gut so, gerade
dafür,
dass das Steam Deck
ganz beliebt ist.
Stellt euch mal vor,
wäre auch doof gewesen, stellt euch mal vor,
die hätten jetzt jahrelang quasi Linux Gaming
supported und hätten da immer mehr
Zeug entwickelt,
dann hätten sie mal ein Produkt rausgebracht,
was das sich zunutze
macht und das wäre komplett
Bahnen gegangen, das Produkt. Dann ist halt
immer noch die Frage,
inwieweit würde
Valve weiter daran arbeiten.
Aber Gaben
ist ja kein großer Microsoft und kein
großer Windows-Only-Fan, das hat er ja schon
öfters gesagt.
Das hat er ja schon öfters
gesagt.
Witzigerweise auch so eine,
habe ich zumindest so den Eindruck,
so ein bisschen persönliche Mischen
von Gaben.
Da kommt übrigens auch
der Sache zugute,
dass Microsoft selber
gar nicht mehr
so scharf
auf Windows ist wie früher.
Man darf nicht vergessen,
Windows war früher die Grundlage für sehr vieles
von Microsoft. Das ganze
Software-Ökosystem mit Office und drumherum
und alles mögliche, das war ja eines der großen
Dinger von Microsoft.
Und da war ja Microsoft
sehr, wie kann man das nennen,
also sehr
aggressiv unterwegs.
Und heute
interessiert die das, würde ich mal
behaupten, tatsächlich schon ein bisschen weniger.
Weil sie halt hauptsächlich ihr Geld
zwar immer noch mit Windows
und Dürrens, aber auch sehr viel mit Services
und Cloud-Geschichten verdienen.
Deswegen sind die da wahrscheinlich gar nicht so
böse drum.
Ist ja was cool, ja.
Wenn es ein
Windows-Subsystem
oder besser gesagt ein
äh
ein
Linux-Kernel
Windows-Modul oder sowas
gäbe, also ein offizielles.
Quasi so eine Art
offizielles Wine
von Microsoft.
Aber das werden wir wahrscheinlich nicht sehen.
Wobei ich da sagen muss,
früher hätte ich sowas für ausgeschlossen gehalten.
Mittlerweile
zumindest in Teilen
nicht mehr.
Ich glaube nie, dass sowas kommen wird.
Ja, quasi
ein umgedrehtes WSL, genau.
Also ich glaube nicht,
dass wir sowas sehen werden.
Aber ich halte das nicht mehr 100% ausgeschlossen
so viel wie früher noch.
Weil Microsoft ja auch sehr viel
Wert darauf legt, dass gerade im
Server- und Cloud-Umfeld
ihre Sachen auch auf
sehr viel Wert ist vielleicht übertrieben gesagt, aber
mehr Wert
mittlerweile drauf
legt, dass sie da drauf laufen.
Und
guckt euch an, Microsoft SQL
Server läuft mittlerweile auch unter Linux.
Ich weiß nicht, warum man das macht. Also
bei mir auf der Arbeit gibt es einen Service, der
benutzt das. Ich verstehe bis heute nicht warum, aber okay.
Ja, ja.
Das wäre doch das gleiche.
Das wäre doch das gleiche im Prinzip.
Dann würden die Linux benutzen, unter Windows
quasi, aber die bräuchten ja immer noch
so eine Windows-Kompatibilitäts-
Schicht. Zumindest mal
für
die nächsten 30 Jahre.
Also,
so ganz ausgeschlossen halte ich es mittlerweile nicht
mehr, aber
dran glauben tue ich auch nicht.
Ich habe echt scheiße gepennt, Leute.
Munges.
Ich habe vor nicht allzu langer Zeit einen Linux-Umstieg
versucht mit Dual-Boot. Muss sagen, ich hatte
immer wieder...
Ja. Ja, gerade
am Anfang, wenn man da nicht dran gewöhnt ist, ist das glaube ich
ganz normal.
Und
selbst wenn man dran gewöhnt ist,
gibt es halt immer mal so die ein oder anderen
Sachen, gerade wenn man die unter Linux noch nicht gemacht hat
oder was Neues ausprobiert.
Da muss man mal ein bisschen basteln.
Man ist ja unter Windows auch nicht viel anders.
Aber bei Linux muss man sich da manchmal
ein bisschen
durchfummeln.
Manche Sachen gehen halt auch einfach gar nicht richtig,
wo ich sage, ey, das sollte nicht sein.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du die
nicht die passende Grafikkarte hast,
dann schöpsel mal ein High-DPI-Display
dran und versuch mal beispielsweise
unter Linux Mint
da ordentliche Skalierung einzustellen.
Da kannst du nur einstellen 100%
oder 200%
und das dazwischen funzt es nicht richtig.
Also, gibt schon ein paar Sachen.
Und ich sage mal so, ich lasse ja
gerade an dieser ganzen
Wayland und
nicht nur Wayland, also
an diesen ganzen riesen Diskussionen
immer, ich lasse da ja oftmals
kein gutes Haar dran, weil ich finde,
dass da
eigentlich fast schon
zu viel diskutiert wird
und sich
gegenseitig geflamed wird,
anstatt dass sich was passiert.
Wie gesagt, mein Lieblingsbeispiel dafür ist immer,
gehen wir mal von Wayland weg,
mein Lieblingsbeispiel ist immer noch
Video Decoding, also
GPU Video Decoding
unter Linux. Unter Windows,
und ich bin mir auch relativ sicher unter
macOS, geht das seit
Leute, seit wann
geht GPU Decoding unter
Windows
für H.264
bestimmt 15 Jahre schon.
Bestimmt 15 Jahre
geht das schon unter Windows.
Also sprich, was ich damit meine ist,
wenn ihr jetzt auf YouTube geht und macht
ein neues Keck Wait,
ein neues Max FPS Video auf,
ganz neu,
dann habt ihr kaum
CPU Last.
Ihr habt kaum CPU Last, weil
die Grafikkarte das Video decodet.
So, macht ihr das gleiche
unter Linux. Ich kann es euch tatsächlich
mal zeigen, weil ich in der
VM unterwegs bin und in der VM prinzipiell
kein GPU Decoding funktioniert.
Und
wenn ihr das Video hier jetzt anmacht, dann seht ihr,
bam, haben wir hier ordentliche Auflösung.
Dann seht ihr,
zack, wir haben schon ordentlich
CPU Last. Naja gut, das ist jetzt ein bisschen klein.
Das Video passiert jetzt auch nicht viel.
Also ich müsste vielleicht mal irgendwie sowas hier machen.
Ne, das ist Reaction
auf,
ein bisschen mehr bewegt, ja.
Da seht ihr, zack,
CPU Last geht schon ein bisschen hoch,
weil die CPU
das Video decoden muss. Ja, unter Windows wäre das
so gut wie 0
bei der CPU.
So, und das ist so ein Ding,
das ist halt so ein Ding,
wo man sich sagt, ey, muss das
wirklich irgendwie 10 Jahre dauern?
Bis das halbwegs auf Linux funktioniert?
Und das funktioniert ja heute noch nicht mal
in allen Konstellationen richtig, ja.
Unter Linux ist dann immer das Problem, okay,
du willst GPU Decoding
von Videos im Browser haben.
Wer muss da alles was für
machen? Und
wer blamt wen, dass er
es verkackt hat, so? Also da gibt's
die Möglichkeit, müssen es die Browserhersteller
machen, müssen es die Mesa-Treiberhersteller machen,
müssen es die Grafikkartenhersteller machen,
muss im Linux-Kernel irgendwas passieren,
muss vielleicht bei dem jeweiligen Desktop
Environment was angepasst werden, muss dann
vielleicht in Qt oder GTK
was gemacht werden, muss da
in irgendwelchen Grafik-Zwischenschnitte...
So, und die Diskussion
in Linux atmen dann
meistens aus,
dass sich
ein paar Leute
5 Jahre plus blamen,
dass der andere das
hätte machen müssen und
das eigene Produkt da nicht für zuständig
ist und sonst was.
Ja...
Und dann dauert das.
Meines Wissens nach, ich hab's jetzt
schon eine Weile
nicht ausprobiert,
meines Wissens nach, wobei das stimmt gar nicht, doch,
ich hab's ausprobiert und das war gar nicht so easy,
wie ich gedacht hätte. Ich hab mir doch so ein Mini-PC
gekauft, da mit Linux drauf, bisschen rum
gebastelt. Bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ob ich am Ende GPU-Decoding zu
laufen bekommen hab, ich glaub schon.
Zumindest, das Ding ist,
das funktioniert prinzipiell dann erstmal
nur mit dem richtigen Grafikkartentreiber,
mindestens in Browser-Version X,
die man meistens hat,
aber das ist nicht das Problem.
Eventuell braucht man noch irgendwelche
Spezial-Flags in den Browser-Settings,
die man einschalten muss, dass es funktioniert.
Und dann funktioniert das auch nicht
für alle Codecs,
wie es beispielsweise unter Windows funktioniert.
Also wenn ich jetzt, also H.264,
so dieses Standard-Video-Format
des Internets aktuell,
das funktioniert, aber sobald
das Ding dann, sagen wir mal, H.265
oder VP9 ist,
selbst wenn das, sagen wir mal, die Grafikkarte
prinzipiell könnte, mit den Decodern,
geht dann nicht. Dann brauchst du
dann wieder einen Zusatz-Browser-Plugin,
was YouTube-Videos
standardmäßig forst auf H.264
und nicht einfach, es ist halt
für'n Arsch, ja, so Dinger.
Das sind dann auch
die Punkte, die mich unter Linux regelmäßig abfacken.
Z-Funktion unter Gnome,
Wayland, ja gut, das liegt wahrscheinlich daran,
das ist jetzt meine Vermutung,
weil Wayland ja nicht sowas wie X ist.
So,
sondern im Prinzip jeder Desktop
Wayland selbst
implementiert, wenn man so will.
Und manche Sachen sind halt
bei Hyperland implementiert und bei Gnome
nicht, und auch manchmal in
inkompatibler Art und Weise, wie beispielsweise
es letztens diese Diskussion gezeigt
hat um
Icons von Fenstern,
um Status-Icons,
gab's letztens eine große Diskussion
um Status-Icons in Fenstern,
ob das
erlaubt ist, dass ein
Fenster quasi
Icons setzen darf,
wie gesagt, da wird
ewig und drei Tage
wird da diskutiert.
Funktioniert bei Linux nicht.
Okay, dann habe ich Steam
auf Windows und Linux...
Okay, genau.
Ja, das sind so kleine Sachen.
Ah, stimmt, es ist gut, dass du das ansprichst.
Ja, da gibt's tatsächlich auch noch Probleme,
da hab ich auch schon von gehört,
dass Screensharing Probleme macht.
Das muss man wohl auch mit Teams
Probleme machen, Screensharing mit Teams
unter Linux.
Vom Hörensagen, Leute,
vom Hörensagen. Könnt ihr mir mal sagen,
wie das ist. Verwendet jemand von euch Teams
unter Linux und
tut da Screensharing?
Also, bei mir
früher hat das funktioniert, aber
auf der alten Arbeit
hat das funktioniert.
Auf der alten Arbeit habe ich Teams verwendet
und
ja, was jetzt?
Ja oder nein?
Ist das jetzt nope oder yo?
Also 50-50.
Also,
als ich noch
auf der alten Arbeit war,
ah ja, okay.
Als ich noch auf der alten Arbeit war,
da habe ich Teams verwendet
im Browser unter Linux.
Das nicht zusätzlich installiert,
ich habe das im Browser verwendet.
Und ich bilde
mir ein, ich habe das nicht oft gebraucht, aber
ich bilde mir ein, da hat Screensharing ganz gut
funktioniert. Auch
auf meinem i3
Desktop mit
zwei Bildschirmen
ist HDR Support mittlerweile
ein Thema unter Linux. Das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Das habe ich nicht ausprobiert in letzter Zeit und mich auch nicht mit
beschäftigt. Ich gebe die Frage mal
gerne hier Chat.
Sagt mal,
jemand schon mal HDR probiert in letzter
Zeit unter Linux?
Ich meine, dass das prinzipiell kein Ding ist, wenn die Hersteller
da mitmachen, sieht man ja beispielsweise,
an Android, Android TV
boxen, da ist HDR gar kein Ding.
Ich würde vermuten,
das liegt an der eingesetzten Grafikkarte
und dem jeweiligen Treiber, ob das funzt.
Wissen tue ich nicht. Weiß nicht, vielleicht wisst ihr das.
Wie ist jetzt HDR Support Linux?
Okay, also.
Guck mal, das Arch-Wiki, das weiß
doch Bescheid. Okay, mit Wayland
kannst du schon mal vergessen.
Mit KDE Plasma 6 ist es experimental.
Ah ja.
Also ich würde sagen, das funktioniert
nur so semi, oder?
Also würde ich sagen, funzt es nicht richtig.
Ich verwende
HDR auch nicht unter Windows.
Ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher, ob mein Display überhaupt
HDR unterstützt, ehrlich gesagt.
Ist das so? Okay.
Ja, das ist aber wieder ein weiterer
Punkt, dass so Sachen manchmal unter Linux
einfach sehr, sehr langsam sind
und lange dauern. Kannst du auch
nichts machen, ne? So, lasst uns
doch mal kurz gucken, was denn so unter GitHub
auf GitHub trendet.
Weekly. Okay.
Habt ihr mitgekriegt, dass die
Linux Rust,
die, die, die,
wie nennt man das richtig?
Die Rust in
Linux Kernel
Interface, Leute,
weiß gar nicht, wie das richtig heißt.
Diese Rust Support
im Linux Kernel,
dass da wohl der Typ,
der Haupt-Maintainer
oder der Haupt-Entwickler irgendwie zurückgetreten ist,
weil er keinen Bock hatte,
sich mit
den anderen
Leuten weiter zu streiten.
Das ist auch so ein Ding,
was du so in der
Open Source Ecke öfters hast,
solche Diskussionen. Ich hab
nen Ausschnitt gesehen
aus einem
Konferenztalk
von dem
ich kann
ja mal die News zeigen hier.
Rust Linux
Rücktritt
Main-Tainer
findet man nix.
Rust for Linux Main-Tainer
steps down in frustration.
Foronix, wisst ihr, wisst ihr was?
Foronix
an sich kann man, ist das für solche
News nicht schlecht, aber wisst ihr, was das Schlimmste
an Foronix ist?
Die Comment-Section, Alter.
Die Comment-Section.
Meine Güte, Alter, die Leute hier.
Das ist, das ist schlimmer,
das ist fast schlimmer
als das Heise-Forum.
Da hast du auch, ey, ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Da hast du solche
also, letztens
ich weiß nicht mal, ich weiß nicht mal, welche News
das war. Es könnte, es könnte sogar
es könnte sogar diese News hier gewesen
sein. Es könnte diese News hier gewesen sein. Ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher.
Ja, es ist, es ist fast schlimmer als Heise.
Es könnte sogar diese News gewesen sein.
Da hab ich mal die Comments ein bisschen
durchgescrollt und keine Ahnung, irgendwie auf
Seite, ich sag jetzt mal auf Seite
11 oder so, ging's dann darum,
dass, das müsst ihr euch mal
vorstellen, ja.
Die Diskussion ist dann so weit abgetrifftet
nach ein paar Seiten, dass es dann darum
ging, dass Linux, dass Rust im
Linux-Kernel angeblich zu Vogue ist
und deswegen raus
muss. Wo ich mir denke, Alter,
wie stellen die immer diese
Zusammenhänge her und
wie kann man sich da, also
die Diskussion wär mir zu
bescheuert. Nicht
Linux zu Vogue, Rust, Rust ist zu
Vogue, gab's die Diskussion
irgendwo. Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, das ist sogar diese, diese,
diese News, dieser Newspost hier.
Oh nein.
An, anscheinend nicht. Dann ein anderer
Newspost, aber auch zum gleichen Thema.
Da hab ich gedacht, was zum Teufel, was ist
bei euch los, man?
Ich, ich hab's auch nicht, ich hab's auch nicht
verstanden, ja.
Ich hab durch die Comments
durchgeklickt, da hab ich mir gedacht,
wie kommt ihr denn jetzt auf dieses Thema?
Ja. Das ist sicherlich
ein Thema, wo die Leute im Internet
heiß drüber diskutieren, aber
ich hätte das nicht wirklich
unter einem
Linux
Rust Maintainer
tritt zurück
Newsartikel erwartet, ja.
Ja, zumindest das ist
das, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte.
Ich hab einen Konferenztalk gesehen,
von, von,
von diesem Haupt,
ich wollte sagen, von dem Main Maintainer,
aber das ist ein bescheuertes Wort,
von dem, von dem Hauptmaintainer,
von dieser, von, von dem Rust Support
im Linuxkörner, und
in diesem Konferenztalk,
mitten in dem Konferenztalk,
ich hab da nur so zwei, drei Minuten Ausschnitt geguckt,
wobei man da Fairness halber
sagen muss, er hat anscheinend auch wirklich gesagt,
am Anfang, dass die Leute, wenn sie Fragen haben, direkt so
einfach sich melden sollen,
zumindest mitten, mitten
im Konferenztalk
hat der Lead Maintainer,
genau, der Konferenztalk vom Lead Maintainer,
das ist also quasi von Rust im Linuxkörner,
ähm,
hat
eine Frage bekommen,
von einem der, ja,
Maintainer von anderen Teilen
des, äh,
Kernels, der Rust
nicht mag,
und der Rust nicht kann,
und Rust nicht lernen will, und,
und, äh, das alles scheiße
findet,
und er hat ihn auf sehr, sagen wir mal, passiv
aggressive Art gefragt,
was der ganze Scheiß eigentlich soll.
So nach dem Motto, er kann nicht erwarten,
dass die irgendwie Rücksicht nehmen auf
Rust, und er versteht gar nicht, warum sowas überhaupt
gemacht wird, es wird immer dafür,
es wird immer kaputt sein, weil
ihr nicht Schritt halten könnt mit der Entwicklung von
den C-Interfaces, und
warum macht ihr diesen, also, das war richtig
für'n Arsch. Also,
selbst wenn er das, also meiner Meinung nach,
selbst wenn er das denkt,
denken kann ja jeder, was er will,
dann
sollte das vielleicht nicht mit ihm
öffentlich während
einer Präsentation auf einer
Konferenz diskutieren.
Und das ging ihm wohl an
mehreren Punkten so, und ziemlich auf den Sack.
Was das
bedeutet, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob's da so
eine gescheite Definition gibt, das ist, wenn du halt
besonders aufmerksam bist, ja,
wenn du besonders wach bist
gegenüber bestimmten Themen,
und das dichte ich
da jetzt dazu, dass viele Leute,
die der Meinung sind,
sie sind besonders woke,
sich auch viele Sachen einbilden, die
gar nicht da sind.
So nach dem Motto, die versuchen dann überall
irgendwas Schlimmes zu erkennen,
vielleicht auch da, wo gar nichts ist,
oder zumindest keine,
sagen wir mal, irgendwie so bösartige Intention
dahinter war, ja.
Also, das ist aber ein Thema, ey,
da geht's ja im Internet
übelst drüber und drunter,
ich hätte jetzt aber nicht erwartet,
dass in einem
Newspost, wo's um
Rust Support im Linux-Kernel
geht, da die
Institution drüber losgeht, aber
Foronix-Forum ist so ein
spezielles
Ding, also, ich würde sagen,
das ist fast noch ein Ticken schlimmer als
das Heise-Forum.
Ja. Ja, und
laut der anderen Seite sind ja
sonst alle, die das, also alle, die
quasi nicht
vom Gegenteil überzeugt sind,
ne, sind
Schlafschafe, das haben sie auf Deutsch immer
gerne. Ist auch so ein richtig dummes
Wort, Alter. Ach, das ist,
die Leute haben echt
allen Dachschaden.
Ah, wir haben hier einen YouTube-Link posten.
Zu dem Konferenztalk, ja, ja,
kannst, also, falls das das ist, kannst du machen.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt aber nicht an.
Kannst, könnt ihr euch angucken, wenn ihr euch
angucken, das ist echt, also, falls das der
Konferenztalk ist,
guck mal, ob das das ist, was ich meine.
Ja, ja, ja, ja,
ist es.
Warum ist denn das überhaupt Fullscreen?
Was ist denn das schon wieder hier hin?
YouTube-Schrott.
Ne, es ist gar nicht Fullscreen. YouTube macht komische,
komische Dinge.
Genau. Ja, also, der, der Dude hier
in der...
Habt das, habt das gehört schon?
Es geht schon los.
Also,
wenn eine Frage aus dem Publikum
schon, schon sowas enthält,
da weißt du Bescheid, Alter.
Das geht noch ein bisschen weiter,
das geht noch ein bisschen weiter,
ja. Also, der Typ, der
jetzt gerade, also, das ist der Rust-Maintainer
und der, den wir gerade gehört haben,
das ist die Frage aus dem Publikum von einem der nicht
so großen Rust-Fans
unter den Kernel-Entwicklern.
Da weißt du
schon Bescheid, ja.
Danke für den Sub.
Die haben echt Probleme.
Da lob ich mir doch die
Weeps, Alter.
Die sind wenigstens nette Leute.
Da wird nicht geflamed.
Da geht's höchstens drum,
welcher ihrer Lieblingscharacter
stronger ist und sowas.
Aber man verträgt sich.
Hab ich schon rebooted eigentlich?
Ich glaub schon, ne? Egal, ich
reboote nochmal, schadet nix.
Wär übrigens die
tägliche Dosis von
Verschwörungstheorien und
Dingern, von denen man
sich fragt,
wie kann man sowas
ungefragt einfach
glauben?
Wer die Dosis
der Verschwörungstheorien und
merkwürdigen Sachen noch nicht erreicht hat,
der kann sich mal auf Reddit angucken,
das Subreddit, ich bin 40 und
Schwurbler. Ich persönlich halte
auch nix davon, alles damit abzutun.
Also auch so
valide Sachen, so nach dem Motto
alle Schwurbel-Zeug. Aber was da
gepostet wird, ist echt teilweise
Haare streuen, wo man sich denkt, Leute,
das siehst du doch schon.
Keine Ahnung.
Drei Tage so gegen den
Wind, dass das fake ist.
Stimmt.
Vielleicht sollte man da besser
nicht hingehen, sonst hat man das ganze
in der
Timeline. Wie das Reddit hieß?
Ich bin 40 und Schwurbler oder sowas.
Reddit.
Ich bin 40 und Schwurbler.
Ich kenn das Subreddit
auch nur, weil
ich das ab und zu von
der Reddit-App empfohlen krieg.
Ich bin 50 und lustig ist auch nicht schlecht.
Ich bin 50 und
lustig, da ist so der
ultrakrasse Boomer-Humor am Start.
Wie gesagt,
da hab ich auch diesen super cringigen Post
gesehen mit diesem
Teufel-Emoji, den ich hier
immer zitiere, wenn es um
unlustigen und cringigen
Boomer-Humor geht. Das ist gut.
Das lese ich auch öfters.
Letzter Preis.
Letzter Preis ist nice.
Was ich auch ganz gerne
lese ist das
Azubi-Subreddit.
Das heißt einfach nur Azubi.
Weil ich es immer haarsträubend finde, was da
teilweise abgeht.
Was da mit den...
Kennt jemand das Azubi-Subreddit
und hat jemand die Story von
Copac oder wie der heißt mitgekriegt?
Nur mal so Interesse halber.
Ich glaub Coptec
oder Copac, irgendwie hieß der Typ da.
Das war...
Wie hieß der?
Wollen wir mal kurz gucken.
Reddit
Coptec
oder Copac?
Irgendwie so.
Also,
man weiß natürlich
nicht, ob das echt ist, weil
Reddit und da kannst du alles posten.
Ich versuch das jetzt mal
aus dem Kopf so halbwegs wiederzugeben.
Ein User mit dem Namen
irgendwie Copac oder Coptec
oder sowas in der Richtung.
Hat nen Post gemacht auf, ich glaub dem
Azubi-Subreddit auf Deutsch.
Dass
er Bedenken hat,
dass sich seine Firma irgendwie nicht an
ich glaube nicht an
Mindestlohn-Geschichten und
andere Vorgaben hält.
Irgendwie sowas war das, glaub ich.
Bin mir da ganz sicher.
Und da haben die Leute drauf geantwortet
und haben gesagt, boah hier das ist ja voll
Kackla und
das geht so gar nicht.
Und hast ein paar Tage nix
von ihm gehört und den nächsten
Post den du von ihm siehst
ist ein
ist ein Richtigstellungs-
Post so. Ja hallo hier ist
wieder Copac und
die Firma bei der ich arbeite
ist selbstverständlich
vollkommen nice
und nichts mit Mindestlohn
verstößen und alles.
Wo man sich so gedacht hat, okay
den Post hat der Chef selbst
verfasst und hat Copac im Keller
eingesperrt oder sowas.
Ja also
ich kriegs nicht mal so ganz
wiedergegeben, aber
die Story hat da bestimmt
zwei, drei Wochen so die Runde gemacht.
Das ist übrigens auch
so ein Ding, wo ich immer ein bisschen
vorsichtig wäre. Also
angenommen man ist jetzt Azubi oder irgendwo
irgendwo angestellt oder auch der Chef
ist es letztendlich ja auch egal.
Ich wäre immer ein bisschen vorsichtig, was ich
auf Reddit poste,
wenn es zu
viele
Informationen also
wie soll ich das sagen, wenn es zu viele
Informationen enthält, die sich
gegenseitig ausschließen und man deswegen halt
drauf kommt
wer es ist. Wisst ihr was ich meine?
Also wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel schreibt
ich arbeite bei einem großen Finanzdienstleister
das ist kein Problem.
Da es gibt so viele große Finanzdienstleister
da wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht dahinter kommen.
Aber wenn du jetzt sagst
ich arbeite bei
einem der großen vier Wirtschaftsprüfer
Unternehmen. Da gibt es schon mal
nicht so viele. Aber immer noch zu viele Leute
um drauf zu kommen.
Und der nächste Post ist
oder sagen wir mal
im nächsten Post steht dann beispielsweise
Letztens war bei uns
irgendwie IT mäßig
eine größere Panne.
Und im nächsten Post findest du dann
ja in der Abteilung sowieso.
Und wenn du diese drei Posts anguckst
dann weißt du okay
der Typ arbeitet bei einem der großen
vier Finanzdienstleister
die hatten letztens eine IT Panne. Da hast du schon
mal die Sache höchstwahrscheinlich auf
einen Dienstleister eingeschränkt.
Und wenn du noch weitere Informationen von dem
Typ dir anguckst, dann kannst du
sogar noch vielleicht sagen
ungefähr in welche Richtung
der arbeitet.
Ja also da wäre ich echt ein bisschen
vorsichtig, wenn man mit seinem Hauptdecker
einen Account postet
und Informationen
also quasi zu
seinen eigenen Sachen
was schreibt,
dass man das nicht so einfach zuordnen kann.
Das ist ja
Das ist der Post
Copact
Genau Copact
Ja
Und der hat dann
Oh ne ne ne ne
Copact. Das Profil war ich nicht.
Du findest dann relativ schnell
du findest die Leute teilweise relativ schnell
und da würde ich halt aufpassen
und wenn dann dein vierter Post ist
wie scheiße
es denn da und da läuft
und dass du vielleicht sogar noch
Probleme siehst, wie da Sachen
abgerechnet werden und sonst was
und die aus den letzten drei
Posts allerdings schon relativ gut erkennen
können, wo du arbeitest
vielleicht auch ungefähr jemand der intern
sich da auskennt, anhand der Informationen
vielleicht noch erkennt welche Abteilung das ist und so.
Also man kann dann mit
den passenden Informationen auch
relativ gut
die Leute identifizieren, also
wenn ihr lästern wollt, so kurz
gesagt, wenn ihr lästern wollt
über euren Ausbildungsbetrieb oder über euren
Arbeitgeber oder auch über eure Mitarbeiter
oder whatever, es ist ja egal aus welcher
Richtung das kommt
dann macht es mit einem neuen Account
oder achtet halt wirklich genau
drauf was ihr schreibt
macht es lieber mit einem neuen Account
weil gerade durch so ein bisschen
Cross-referenzieren
eurer Post-History kommt man
bei vielen Leuten doch schon ganz gut drauf
gerade wenn die
wenn die aktiv sind
auf solchen Subreddits
also ich mein, was
der Lieblings-Anime ist, von dem juckt wahrscheinlich
kein, aber wenn der öfters hier immer Zubi-Subreddit
oder bei den anderen postet
und halt auch was zu sich preisgibt, da kommst du relativ
schnell drauf
je nachdem was er schreibt, wo die Leute arbeiten
ja
ja gut, da sind jetzt Leute, die sind
ja also ich mein, da sollte man sich
im Vorfeld eigentlich klar sein, dass interne Sachen
öffentlich auf Reddit posten nie eine gute Idee ist
also ich mein
ich hab auch schon
Team-Chats anonymisiert
gepostet, allerdings dann nur zwei Sätze
und die nichts mit der jeweiligen Arbeit zu tun haben
so nach dem Motto
das System ist kaputt
ja welches? Das System mit dem wir täglich
arbeiten
ja solche Sachen werden dann mal gescreenshottet
Namen rausgemacht und dann so
gepostet, aber nach der Null
Bezug dazu
aber wenn man irgendwelche internen Sachen
postet im Internet, dann ist man schon ziemlich
blöd
ganz ehrlich
da ist Leuten echt nicht mehr zu helfen
bist du schon 40?
ja, auf welche Weise
nutzt du eigentlich Windows und Linux parallel?
meinst das hier?
das ist ne VM
eine VM, wie die coolen Leute das sagen
das ist VMware Workstation
einfach im Fullscreen
und auf dem zweiten Windows-Desktop
also guck hier unten, du kannst ja unter Windows
mittlerweile mehrere Desktops haben
Desktop 1, 2, 3
und mit der Tastenkombination, nämlich
Control, Windows-Taste
und Pfeiltasten
kannst du die Windows-Desktops durchschalten
und auf meinem zweiten Windows-Desktop ist
die VM
und mit einer Tastenkombination tapp ich raus
aus der VM und dann kann ich die Windows-Tastenkombination
verwenden
ja
das ist nicht nur das Setup, was ich hier
für Streaming habe
den Ordner gibt es nicht auf dem Desktop
guck
das neueste VM kann man auf deutschen Windows nicht
echt nicht? warum nicht?
by the way, ich hab das
stimmt, das wäre gar nicht schlecht
dafür ein Commando zu machen
ey, das ist auch der Grund, warum ich wahrscheinlich
das neueste VM erstmal nicht installieren werde
weil, man weiß ja nicht
was da abgeht
Beklärst du das jede Woche zweimal?
ist ja auch für viele Leute
die neu hier in den Stream kommen erstmal mit
eines der auffälligsten Sachen
dass ich easy und schnell wechseln kann
zwischen Windows und Linux
das finde ich geil, dass sowas überhaupt hardcoded wird
normalerweise gibt es ja für Windows
dort so
Alias-Dinger
also beispielsweise
auch für den
Ordner
in dem Programme
quasi ihre temporären Sachen abspeichern
da gibt es ja so einen Alias-Fart
den man verwenden kann
der unabhängig immer im richtigen Verzeichnis
rauskommt, egal in welcher
Sprache das Betriebssystem ist
aber solche Sachen kann ich mir nur erklären
wird nicht richtig getestet
anderweitig kann ich mir das nicht erklären
ehrlich gesagt, weil ich meine
sowas müsste doch
ich meine
das mindeste
was man testen sollte, wenn man eine neue
Softwareversion rausbringt, ist doch
lässt sie sich überhaupt installieren und starten, oder?
also ich meine, darunter
ja gut, die
Entwicklung von VMware Workstation ist seit
Jahren schon
fast nicht mehr existent
VMware Workstation
oh, jetzt muss ich mich mal hinsetzen, ich habe die ganze Zeit
meinen Schreibtisch hier hochgefahren
mach mal
ich fahr den mal wieder runter
ich möchte eigentlich langsam von Windows weg, allerdings hätte ich
es gern noch parallel für ab und zu mal Gaming
vermutlich
ja, nee
ähm
also das kann man machen
es geht
also du könntest beispielsweise
also Proxmox ist wahrscheinlich dann eh nicht so das
sinnigste
weil dann müsstest du ja Proxmox als
Hostsystem verwenden oder sowas, hä
du könntest KVM machen
du könntest dir eine KVM
anlegen
und GPU Pass Through
machen
für eine Windows VM
aber ganz ehrlich, das ist in der Handhabung nicht so schön
meiner Meinung nach zumindest
das ist in der Handhabung nicht so schön
weil die Grafikkarte ist ja dann quasi
in einem eigenen PC
wenn du so willst, das heißt du brauchst auch einen eigenen Monitor Output
wo du das anschließt
brauchst auch eine zweite Grafikkarte
für das
äh, Hausbetriebssystem
kannst dazwischen keine Daten gescheit sharen
so mit Copy & Paste und so
also schön ist es nicht
ich finde das ist eigentlich eines der
umständlich
umständlicheren Sachen
dieses Windows
Windows VM Gedöns
also wenn ich, also ich persönlich
finde mein Setup am besten, wenn es darum geht
man will volle
Kompatibilität zu
ja
finde ich trotzdem nicht sinnvoll
volle Kompatibilität zu Windows Sachen haben will
finde ich meine Lösung mit
eine Linux VM unter Windows im Fullscreen
eigentlich am besten
und das stimmt, also
Linux Gaming mit Proton
hat hauptsächlich Probleme mit Anti-Cheat
da habe ich mich am Anfang des Streams schon drüber ausgelassen
ne
das ist eine VM
das ist eine ganz normale
VM in VMA Workstation im Fullscreen auf dem zweiten Desktop
aber die reicht ja für alles
ich meine die VM hat jetzt schon ein bisschen
Wumms
die hat 64 GB RAM
250 GB SSD
und
8 CPU Cores
also mehr als
viele Desktop Rechner alleine haben
bei manchen Leuten
aber das bräuchte die auch nicht
die würde
ist jetzt nicht so das i3
so Ressourcen hungrig ist
dass das unter 8 CPU Cores nicht läuft
boah Leute jetzt wenn ich hier sitze bin ich übelst müde
so
oh was ist denn das
nice
jetzt wissen wir Bescheid
aber wenn Copilot kommt
nimmt er dann nicht auch den halt von
ja
wobei Copilot aktuell glaube ich
erst einmal nur Preview kommen soll im Oktober habe ich heute morgen gelesen
und ich weiß gar nicht
ob das für alle Rechner dann überhaupt gilt
oder ob das so ein spezielles Copilot Notebook sein muss
ja
das ist auch ein Feature was ich nicht haben will
Copilot Plus ist übelster
übelster Crap
wisst ihr ich habe ja gar keine Probleme
damit das es sowas prinzipiell gibt
aber das sollte
Zusatzsoftware sein
und kein
Kernbestandteil von Windows meiner Meinung nach
ja
ihr werdet das ähnlich sehen
das ist halt scheiße
um nicht zu sagen es suckt
ich frage ob es dabei bleibt
ja
angeblich kommt das Feature nur deaktiviert
also
wie gesagt ich glaube
dass an der Stelle Microsoft sogar
dass es erstmal deaktiviert kommt
was ich Microsoft nicht glaube ist
dass es für immer deaktiviert bleiben wird
defaultmäßig
ja vielleicht ja auch zurecht
überlegen dass den Scheiß eigentlich keiner haben will
außer sie selbst
da bin ich
wie gesagt ich arbeite ja in der Finanzbranche
in Frankfurt da bin ich auch sehr
gespannt drauf wie das laufen wird
das muss abschaltbar sein
es wird
im Leben nichts dort
ein
Third Party Desktop
Recording Tool
erlaubt
Leute ich gehe jetzt off
ich kann auch nicht länger streamen
ich will jetzt wieder hinlegen
ich habe kaum gepennt heute Nacht
ich lege mich jetzt wieder hin
heute nur ganz kurz
aufwachen streamen
machts gut bis dann
see you